à vandoncourt près de montbéliard il n'y
a pas en l'air mais c'est un village
avec ciments maire en 1971 lorsqu'il est
élu jean-pierre maillard salins sans
étiquette révolutionne la politique
locale
dans les faits c'est bien lui l'élu du
village dé son projet c'est d'impliquer
les 600 habitants de vandoncourt dans la
vie de la commune
il ne s'agit donc pas de diriger des
gens il s'agit de les mettre en
animation et en mouvement et une pac le
mouvement est déclenché et j'ai ça qui
est intéressant et bien une fois que ce
mouvement est en route
on ne peut pas l'arrêter en plus du
conseil municipal trois instances ont
été mises en place le conseil des sages
composé de treize personnes âgées
chaque fois que je suis quelque part
avec des gentianes s'armer il faut que
charmeur et le conseil des fous pour les
jeunes et jeunes ont justement une
importance dans la commune on leur a
donné des responsabilités et le conseil
des sociétés qui représente les
associations du village personne
tout ce beau monde se réunit pour
débattre proposer et se répartir les
tâches
il peut être question d'urbanisme de
ramassage des déchets d'expositions
d'animations bref toutes les compétences
d'une mairie entre les mains des
villageois il apparaît difficile de dire
aux gens voilà vous votez tous les 6 ans
vont vous et lisez vos gens et puis
après ben pendant six ans on vous tient
à l'écart de tout ce qui se passe dans
la commune et vous n'êtes plus dans le
coup une implication qui semble naturel
pour les villageois participer à la
communauté c'est justement sortir savoir
réservé un peu de temps en plus de son
métier en plus de sa maison de ses
enfants de son jardin pour donner à
l'extérieur la fin du mandat de jean
pierre maillard salins approche nous
sommes en 1978 et une question cours
dans le village ce que vous avez peur
que finalement cette belle tentative de
vandoncourt s'éteignent avec la
disparition de son maire j'ai
l'impression
moi je vais déjà dit à la radio il ya eu
après le gros lui aurait peut-être
l'avant moyart l'après mariage en 1983
changement de maire
mais la démocratie participative a
perduré à vandoncourt aujourd'hui ils
sont quelques 800 habitants dans le
village toujours associé aux décisions
de la vie en communauté
[Musique]